in this film I'm introducing massively
important new characters rather which
like silver Bay your brother and sister
he's fast and quick and anxious and
she's grounded and thoughtful Wanda and
Pietro Maximoff twins orphaned at 10
when a shell collapse their apartment
building they only have one another it's
kind of just them against the world
is very fast as faster almost as fast as
a bullet he's quick everything is quick
tempered everyone goes so slow for him
didn't see those coming and then Scarlet
Witch you got telekinesis she can move
things and she can get inside your head
so that all your worst fears or doubts
come to the fore maximov girls where can
you start what's so interesting to me is
how connected she is and how grounded
she is with the universe and how much
power she has without realizing it she
messes with all the Avengers to such an
extent that they have to go somewhere
and come back as a unit how are you guys
planning on beating them together
it does take a while for us to
understand who can be trusted and who
can't
and who's on our squad and who isn't